thanks Rado with that in mind let's add
a refresh menu button to our app for
temporary purposes only though otherwise
Rado would be mad at us on Android menu
options are defined in XML and they can
be declared for fragments or activities
when the fragment or activity is created
it inflates this XML into the actual
menu items in the app you'll see that
there are action buttons which are menu
items that appear in the action bar such
as this search menu item this space is
reserved for the most prominent actions
in your app then anything else that's
less important falls into the overflow
menu by tapping on this button with the
three dots these menu items are ordered
from most frequently used to least
frequently used and on larger devices
that have more screen real estate you
can specify that some of these menu
items can actually go into the action
bar if there's room if you go back to
our project in the resources folder
which is called res there's a menu
folder and inside that there's a main
dot XML file if you open that up you see
the menu layout XML and that there's a
single menu option defined for settings
it will never show up as an action in
the action bar meaning that it will be
in the overflow menu you can verify this
by checking the app on your phone to
define the ordering of menu items you
can just add multiple items to this XML
file and then they'll show up in that
order in the app if you don't like the
order though and you want to explicitly
set it then you can specify this order
in category value right now it's set as
a hundred so that the settings menu will
be at the bottom of all the other menu
options that we define in our app the
only menu option that should show up
below the settings menu is the help menu
check out the link for more details